germany has warned against travel to
ukraine and told its nationals to leave
the country following fears that russia
is planning an imminent invasion
german foreign minister anna elena
baerbach said that the crisis was
escalating while on a trip to egypt she
told journalists that she and nato
allies were still working on a
diplomatic solution germany is the
latest country to issue a travel warning
to the region in recent days here's the
german foreign minister
we will keep our embassy in kiev open
but reduce the entire diplomatic staff
there that includes the seconded
employees of our partners and the german
teachers abroad family members will also
leave the country now
our consulate general in donetsk set up
in 2014 will be temporarily relocated to
lev
the foreign office also issues a travel
warning
germans who are there are urged to
consider leaving the country
and for more on this let's bring in dw
chief international editor richard
walker uh can you talk us through this
warning a little bit more yeah nick so
analina barbog described the situation
at the moment in ukraine as precarious
saying that there is no de-escalation
the de-escalation the germans and the
rest of the west have been pushing for
in diplomatic channels in recent weeks
but rather the opposite referring to the
fact that there are large military
exercises going on at the moment by 30
000 russian troops in belarus there are
also naval exercises going on around the
port of sevastopol in crimea which the
russians of course
annexed back in 2014 so pointing to this
and this really chiming in with with
warnings that we've had from the united
states yesterday that it does appear
that some kind of military action could
be imminent
so analina bearbox saying on the basis
of this that they are taking precautions
then around germans in ukraine at the
moment talking about the embassy staff
there not closing the embassy but
reducing the head count there and saying
to germans uh who are in ukraine that
they should think about if it's
essential for them to be there and if
not that they should leave
and can you tell tell us a little bit
about about the timing why this now yeah
well there has been really a kind of a
flurry of concern if you like over the
last 24 hours or so
about the situation there
the exercises that we're seeing in
belarus the naval exercise that i just
mentioned also those both feeding into
that in the united states yesterday
issuing a stark warning that they
believe according to their intelligence
that is possible uh that the russians
may make a military move uh in the next
week or so even while the winter
olympics is still taking place there'd
been some speculation that the russians
might be waiting that out
uh i should stress um
the russian foreign minister spoke to
his american counterpart today on the
phone we know that and the russians are
pushing back so uh sergey lavrov saying
to
tony blinken in that call according to
the russian side that they feel that the
west is trying to provoke up conflict
with this uh talk this public talk of
this aggression well they
yeah i think the russians have quite
often accused the west of things that
you know it's a bit of a mirror game but
look
do we feel now that a russian invasion
is around the corner given
that you know western countries are
getting their nationals to leave
um
it in a background briefing recently one
german um official described it like
this that that they want to look at
capabilities not necessarily intentions
and what they see here and what the
americans are pointing to at the moment
is the capability uh to take some
military action very large numbers of
troops these exercises going on
providing a kind of reason for these
troops to be on the move
um the intentions of course this is a
huge question what does vladimir putin
really want there's been lots of debate
about that that's not completely clear
but the capability
is there
okay thanks so much for that insight dw
chief international editor richard
walker
now moscow denies having any plans to
invade ukraine of course but with more
than 100 000 troops as we just heard
stationed near the border and a ramp up
in military drills tensions are reaching
a fever pitch american president joe
biden is due to speak with russia's
vladimir putin later today in the hope
of averting war
and we're going to go to ukraine now to
see how things look there and talk to dw
correspondent matthias burlinger who is
in the capital kiev matthias germany
joins the list of countries asking its
citizens to leave ukraine as soon as
possible are people likely to evacuate
do you think
well we've heard the foreign minister
she's already announced who is going to
leave
from state organizations that includes
the embassy non-essential stuff their
families and that also includes the
organizations for example
in aid or in other cooperation
that are here on behalf of the german
government on the on the federal budget
they will also evacuate some stuff and
all the companies will go through the
same
they will also have to check with their
insurance companies because once a
warning is issued this has also
consequences on their insurance
companies so uh i would expect that many
people will bring at least their
families out of the country but also
many expats who do not have to be here
might be leaving and also business trips
will be cancelled and have you spoken to
any ukrainians about how they feel about
all these western governments telling
them to to leave it must be unsettling
well yeah it is unsettling of course and
there is a cri a sense of urgency a
sense of crisis here that has i mean
there has been the sense of crisis
before but people have been going about
their daily lives they still do so many
have prepared for it but
this of course makes it much more urgent
and uh i've heard some voices who've
said that they feel like like like
abandoned and there is also a pushback
from the ukrainian government saying
there is no need to panic somewhat
disagreeing with the rhetoric of the
western governments although their tone
has been shifting slightly and they are
also now
insisting that this is a serious matter
let me ask you about that emotion and
perhaps the despair i don't know if i'm
putting words in people's mouths other
you we understand there's some protests
in the capital today can you can you
tell us about that
briefly
yeah despair is the wrong word despair
is the wrong word um there's resolve
here to defend the country many people
have joined these forces and this march
it's not a very big margin
but
this march is of course a signal of is
meant as a signal of unity
and um that um
people here uh are not giving up on
their country there's no
despair in in the way that people would
feel that it's an inevitable fate to be
invaded
okay correspondent matthias
on the situation there thanks so much
and for more insight we're going to
cross to vladimir jacipal from dw
russian who joins us from
london uh vladimir we just heard about
all these western countries getting
their nationals out of the country
suggesting they leave closing embassies
and so on russia has confirmed that it
is reducing its diplomatic staff in
ukraine what's the justification there
um russian foreign ministry indeed
confirmed today that russia is pulling
or has pulled already some of its
diplomatic stuff of the ukraine
fearing provocations from kiev as the
spokeswoman from the russian foreign
ministry say it and this is the
important point whatever happening in
the ukraine or what happened might
happen in the next day or weeks in the
ukraine russia is always blaming the
ukrainians or the west or united states
for what is going to happen there
the russian foreign ministry didn't call
any concrete numbers of how much how
many diplomats are
pulled of the ukraine
russia joined the list of the countries
who has
reducing staff of the ukraines but uh
and this is part of of the russian taxes
or toxic or
always blame the united states
yeah it feels i mean there's a there's a
parallelism and it seems an element of
theater and you know i guess our viewers
will decide who is who is sincere in
withdrawing
their nationals and sensing danger but
let's move on to what's going to be
happening later today the united states
president is scheduled to talk with
vladimir putin by phone
what can we expect to happen to be said
honestly my expectations are very low i
would not expect much from today's talk
between president putin and president
biden
i still hope they can de-escalate them
somehow but i'm afraid we are heading
for divorce because there's like in my
opinion they're reaching the point of no
return some
somewhere end
and i'm not sure um we can solve this
huge diplomatic or military crisis
between russia and the west
with a huge amount of issues problematic
issues by just one call tonight so my
expectations are quite low
yeah it's hard to see how that could
solve everything but look if i can just
ask you about what's going on in russia
how much support is there for the
russian presidents amongst the citizenry
for a possible invasion of ukraine
well one thing is quite sure whatever
president putin decided whatever he
decides to do in the ukraine or what
wherever um russian public will always
support him because russian government
is in a total control of the russian
public opinion so i've just spoke to two
friends from moscow who are completely
surprised by the whole um
how they call it history in the west
because russia is on the right side in
their opinion
and
everything is going um according them
because of the united states trying to
push the ukraine to the nato
so whatever
whatever happens in the next weeks and
in the next days
um united states and in the west would
be blamed by this by russian public
opinion
all right that was dw russians vladimir
yazipuff joining us from london thank
you so much for that insight
and i'm joined now from brussels by our
nato correspondent terry schultz uh
terry germany also now withdrawing
embassy staff and advising citizens to
leave ukraine following you know as we
just heard similar action by the united
states
um the biden administration seems to
think we're at a point of outright
conflict
are they sharing the intelligence about
this with their nato allies
they do seem to think that outright
conflict is at least very possible more
possible than it has been up until now
and they are sharing that intelligence
you heard from richard that president
biden held a video call with key
european leaders and last night at nato
headquarters there was a meeting of all
30 nato ambassadors to share the
intelligence from the united states and
something was really striking after this
meeting and leading up into it nick and
that's that until now european countries
had really been resisting the u.s uh
move to pull it to pull their citizens
out of ukraine to advise them to leave
and once this intelligence just started
coming out yesterday you saw
many many european allies doing just
that starting with norway then the
netherlands and the uk
and now of course we've seen many more
including germany and that says to me
that this intelligence is very credible
that the u.s was able to share with
allies exactly what it was that was
leading them to believe that indeed an
invasion could be imminent
and we just saw of course uh terry the
nato secretary general in that report
welcoming american troops to romania so
nato's ratcheting up its military
posture in in the allied countries that
border ukraine how much of a concern is
that any russian military action could
spread beyond ukraine's borders
well one a key factor is that it's not
just a russian buildup on the border
with ukraine anymore which provides a
bit of a buffer to to nato allies but
currently there are russian and
belarusian military drills going on and
that has brought more forces than have
been seen in belarus since the end of
the cold war according to nato and
belarus borders nato allies directly
latvia lithuania and poland and so you
do now have this russian buildup not
buffered by ukraine but right there on
nato allies and that makes the baltic
states and poland very very nervous and
romania as well and that's why you've
seen the u.s and other allies send
reinforcements to these border countries
a deterrent to russia a warning to
russia that you may not step into nato
territory and we're there waiting for
you and just a a really quick final
question if i may vladimir putin and joe
biden spoke speak on the phone today
what can they say to each other to make
things better
i don't know if it will make things
better but you'll certainly hear the the
u.s president reminding vladimir putin
that that all teed up are these measures
both by europeans and by the united
states that would cause pain to the
kremlin is something that they've said
that they would be sanctions like have
never been used before that would really
not just hurt uh hurt the oligarchs i
mean but would also hurt ordinary
russians i mean the the united states
has said that that uh they they would
really trot out some some sanctions that
they have not been willing to use before
and that's something that president
biden will be making clear to president
putin there is still time to change your
mind if you have in fact decided to
invade ukraine and i would highly
recommend that you do that
all right terry schultz in brussels
thanks so much
you